a partir del próximo lunes los viajeros
completamente vacunados de la unión
europea y eeuu no tendrán que hacer
cuarentena pero francia fue excluida de
este anuncio
londres puso a su vecino en su nueva
lista de viajes bajo la categoría ámbar
plus justificando la medida por
incrementos en la variante beta
parís respondió diciendo que el
incremento de casos de esta variante
está ubicado en territorios de ultramar
como el caso de la isla reunión ubicada
en el océano índico y criticó esta
decisión argumentando que no tiene
fundamento científico y que resulta
discriminatoria oficiales británicos
dicen que la situación será analizada al
final de la siguiente semana
ese será el momento en que revisamos el
sistema semáforo de rojo amarillo y
verde entonces ahí podemos analizar hoy
en día se trata del sistema que permite
a la gente ir y venir la próxima semana
se tratará de qué país entra en cada
categoría eso será lo más pronto haga
oficiales mientras el número de casos de
contagios de kobe 19 en el reino unido
continúa su descenso en la última semana
el número de muertes diarias llegó a sus
niveles más altos desde marzo
advierten que el país no está fuera de
peligro aún es muy buena noticia saber
que los números a nivel comunitario
están bajando pero si uno ve las cifras
en admisiones en hospitales aún están
aumentando exponencialmente aunque estas
medidas suponen un relajamiento los
viajeros deberán realizarse una prueba
de kobe 19 antes de su partida y el
segundo día después de su llegada al
reino unido-